i want you mr cfo to be the smartest
person in the organization i want you
to help me the ceo
to understand better what happened but
even most important to help me to
predict right to to understand well
am i going what i'm doing wrong how can
i do something today
that will help me to do better in the
next quarter of the next
year
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm talking with didi gulfinkel
the co-founder and ceo of data rails
didi was previously the general manager
at cisco and has extensive senior
management experience with the focus on
growth and innovation
he holds a bsc in economics and computer
science and an mba data rails is the
leading fp a solution for excel users
the cloud-based platform automates the
process of consolidating and analyzing
financial data while allowing users to
stay in excel founded in 2015 data rails
is based in tel aviv israel
you know it really the the wave of
technology and how it's impacting
different verticals of our lives or
companies lives and decision making in
general i think it's a you know it's a
phenomenal question taking the human in
the loop who were used to making
decisions based on various tool sets
that they've been given and and how do
we leverage technology in all its ways
to to change that
that decision making process i think
it's just fascinating and obviously
you're at the forefront of that on the
on the fintech side on the fp a side
within
companies and leveraging data and
technology to do exactly just that with
um one of israel's leading uh fintech
and and data startups data rails so
thank you very much for joining me today
my pleasure er actually it's very
interesting uh the point that you were
just erased
in
if you look at the the typical
organization or you look at the the the
different developments or verticals in
in organization so
you will see that
most of the
in
the departments if you go to the sales
marketing hr
there are
i think
most of if not
the the all of the the
the departments and the the use cases um
are managed in
cloud-based application right
you won't find the
vp sales
of the
medium-sized companies that run the the
cells in in excel or in
any any
even even not in monday they they have a
specific sas
solution for each
vertical
but if you go to the financial
department
you will see
a lot of manual
work based on excel
and this is not
because there
aren't any available solution in the
market okay there are solutions in the
market for fb name for for a month's
clause and for a financial reporting but
still the majority and i say majorities
85 90 percent of the
companies still use excel based
processes to run their financials
and i believe that the the the answer
for this question this is the the it's
it's it's it's the key or to understand
first of all to understand what we do in
database the product market fit that we
have and also i think it's the key to
understand how
is it possible to penetrate this market
and and and then get successful
in this for for
the c for the office of the cfo
and
and i believe it should start
with understanding
the role of a spreadsheet or excel
i can use the same it doesn't matter
spreadsheet
and tool
in the
the life of a finance person
and
here i think this is an understanding
that
when i started the company it was a
seven years ago and i worked in cisco i
was a gm i
ran a larger business unit
and
i was so surprised and amazed to see the
the amount of processes
and how cisco rely
on excel
and it of course not because of a
lack of a budget right or
manpower
it's about
the
the magic
or the advantage that excel
brings to their to their users that no
other solution actually provide and it
starts from flexibility
independency
a familiarity
and for financial people i think this is
the the basic for what we are doing for
finance people excel
is
kind of even operation system
or i can say that it's like the canvas
for for the the
for them to to
to create right to to
to take
a ideas
to take a
a models that they
try to to to implement
they open excel
and they start to innovate right without
to say okay i will take this we'll take
that let's see if in this angle
and then they can actually
comply to their
most important role in the organization
which is
i want you mr cfo to be the smartest
person in the organization
right i don't want you just to count
numbers to make sure this is obvious
that everything should be you know there
everything to be uh
to know what are the actors i want you
to help me the ceo
to understand better what happened but
even most important to help me to
predict right to understand where
am i going what i'm doing wrong how can
i do something today
that will help me
to do better in the next quarter or the
next
year
so just to clarify when i wa because you
made an important distinction here that
unlike a lot of sas products that
different teams within a company may use
which are more feature based and they're
they're a part of a larger network of of
tools at their disposal here you're
saying we have to give respect to
spreadsheet or excel as an operating
system it's not a feature to be replaced
it's a it's a canvas of of innovation
and opportunity where every team can now
create with their own sets of tools
within this canvas and that's why it's
it's a different type of beast right
understanding how to
how to modify their habits because once
you take them out of excel it's very
difficult to match the operating system
capabilities of what excel has built
exactly exactly
and this is why in in data wells
the product market field that we found
is that
we do not try to take
the cfo and the financial people out of
excel
what we are trying to do and what we do
is to
keep the flexibility the familiarity
keep the excel
as the
fronted and as the tool that they
actually interact with the system but to
build
a full automation
around excel
this automation actually generates a
database
that
injected today to the excel so excel the
excel is
connected to the database
so they keep seeing using smelling
feeding excel
but
this excel sits on top of a database
so they have they get the full
automation
they get
powerful analytics
all the drill down capabilities slice
and dice virus all this capability
analytics that in in database is almost
a commodity but in excel is
very complex and and and
and
tedious
on top of that because it's a database
and the cloud-based we provide also
collaboration
uh with the web-based dashboard and the
visualization so they actually get a
full product with automation analytics
and visualization
but the core
is excel and not only excel
their existing
excel we do not replace their how to
build your report from scratch
we use the same report the same models
all these
if you look at the uh
programmers okay
they have
the ide right and then build
develop code and code and then they have
product okay
if you look financial people they have
the excel okay that's similar to the ide
they have the excel on the excel that
actually
programming right they adding more and
more models and the results is their
financial
right reports
so
what we do we actually
uh um keep
the the the excel as the ide we keep all
the code okay the programming that they
already invested years over years we we
maintain we keep the the these assets
but we add the automation and the
database uh behind us
and this is actually we found a
different angle
to the market
that
actually exploded we are in with this
product market fit
in two years we got to a
number that
broke any any benchmark in the market in
terms of growth number of customers
revenue uh there is no even
someone in in this area that even close
to this uh to these numbers
taking back a little bit to those five
years of searching for that product
market fit because you mentioned the
companies has been around for about
seven years and and obviously you have a
lot of
you know you have a lot of journey
behind you and i you know this
understanding of what excel is for
operating systems because you know i
think that the traditional person may
come in and say yes of course excel is
you know it's old news we have new
technologies let's disrupt their
environment and let's build a whole new
set of tools for them and let's forget
about this old
uh you know application that that has
been around from the 90s but you're
saying that's actually not the right way
of thinking about this
yes when we when we started
we we knew for sure and this is a fact
that we we relied on then excel
is not a temporary solution and excel is
here to stay
and
the billion one billion user excel users
will not go anywhere okay this is an
assumption by the way i met with
many vcs that said look excel is
belong to the past
don't talk to me about excel it
fair enough
i i
believe the
differently
um
and then
we actually had the feeling that okay we
sit on top of a
oil okay before a treasure a billion
users of excel with many many many
problems and challenges it's it's almost
obvious excel hell okay
but
we try to find a way to to make to build
a business to find a use case to find a
problem specific problem to solve so we
started by building the technology okay
it's it's very
israeli way to build a a company a
technology product and then find the the
market so we start from the technology
and we built a platform
that
knows how to take semi-structured data
from excel okay
and transform it into database structure
database okay
this is a super interesting technology
because also it's no one actually
invested any main power and brain power
in this area
understand excel
just an example okay think about it if
you do a google search okay how many
bluefish in the middle c
okay
if someone actually wrote an article
okay with this information you will get
it in a
in a second right
but if someone made
a research okay
and prepare a spreadsheet
fish
sea
cola
a table very organized very
and
it's a published in there in the in the
the internet
google will not be able to give you the
answer
why because it's what we call
semi-structured
okay
and this is where we we we understand
that there is a gap okay from the
technology perspective there is a gap
let's first close this gap take
semi-structure and organize it in a
structured database
we have
all on its own it's a it's a huge
technological feat that
exactly many amazing researchers are
working on right exactly exactly we we
we succeeded and we have three patents
registered on this technology and it's
it's super
super impressive
with this technology at the beginning we
we try to sell it to
large organizations that rely on excel
banks insurance companies financial
institutions
and
the the the ph or the the values
control your data take all your
semi-structured data your flat excel
files organized it in a centralized
cloud database and then you have full
control data integrity
version control
nice
nice speech
even uh
value but
it was
it
wasn't you know focus vertical what is
the problem that you solved that
integrated like nice
so
and then we played around different use
cases we tried to sell it to a vcs
and to manage their portfolio
private equity is different
and then
from the customer base we have like 10
15 customers
that
half of them
actually use it for consolidation
and then we understood that the
consolidation
and financial people in consolidation
it's a it's a it's a challenge
and it's time consuming
it's the reason for all their manual
processes
so we shifted the the the go to we
didn't change the platform at all we
just shifted the the go to market to
a in the fbna vertical
companies between 50 to 500 employees
this is our
target market
and then and and we started with the
same platform and we brought customers
fpa people with the fbna background to
um
right yeah for the customer success uh a
role
and then once
we did this uh
pivot and we started to sell
this product these people
the product market fit hits like in an
explosion it's a so if we're looking
high level at the problems that
financial planners within organizations
are are dealing with what what are some
what are some questions that data reels
helps them answer in their day-to-day
how would you think through the impact
that this has on on organizations that
are that are leveraging it
actually the the questions and this is a
very
simple and repetitive questions
what happened
last period okay what happened
comparing to
the the previous what happened
and
that unique to this month okay
this is what and second
how
my actuals how the the the facts that i
just realized for the last period how
this affects my
next period my next quarter my next year
this is
what the financial people needs to
answer
months over months months over months
right and so these repetitive questions
that we're looking back at
at the way that excel was before and the
consolidation
the enrichments the data rails provide
so where how do you describe that you
know the before and after so how do they
answer these questions today so before
first of all the the this process of
collecting the data preparing the data
and getting the the results it's it's a
process of a few weeks so usually they
run it once in a quarter okay
and then by the end of the quarter it's
take
almost a month to get to the results so
you get the understanding of the
previous quarter in at the end of the
right the the next time that goes back
to this question of how they take
semi-structured data and you make sense
of it in an automated way right that
that really is slicing
it exactly
once you automate this consolidation
process
and you can do it even on a daily basis
because it's automated so so you don't
need to wait so you have this data
available
not just for for there to see the data
but also to analyze it so every week
every day you can analyze the the the
data compare it to the previous data
before we a week previous month and you
are you sits on top
of your insights in a continuous way so
it's a huge
change in the in the value that the the
the cfo can actually provide
to the to the to the ceo to the board
now is that rails a you know you go in
and it's very much branded a an fpna a
tool for fp as a fintech company if you
will is it a fanta company or is it a
data company because
usually if you say i think that they
won't get terminology if you take care
usually you know payment so it's it's a
it's an
um
it's a software solution company it's
and it's because it sounds to me that
the the soft the technology behind it
and i'm starting to think about you know
the different implications of the
technology you're building here it has
virtues beyond just you know a tool as a
tool for fpmas it has i i can think of
many different use cases where this
would be relevant
100 percent if first there is a
a term called xpna okay this is a
inverted by a by gartner xpna which is
actually
every manager in the organization
need to run planning right and if you
will replace the world the dollar with
the leads so the vp marketing actually
is so of course this tool can
help you to run planning for for every
department
the focus in
the
office of the cfo
is important from from different uh from
um
first because you need to focus go to
market you need to focus and it's
important to uh to to talk the talk to
the language to know who are you talking
with it and this is what
second
the product is getting more and more
finance okay we have built-in analytics
we have models we have things where
benchmarks so we adding on top of the
platform and the data
the pure data consolidation capabilities
we're adding more and more financial
capabilities that make it in an fbna
monster what you call it it's a
specific to the
defense
incredible and the ddi you know 20
minutes go by way too fast to to even
begin talking about you know where the
world is going and i have a way way too
many questions to ask but but i think
that at least this 20 minutes gave me a
little bit of insight as to the way that
you're thinking about you know the the
data as a tool this a question of
consolidation semi-structured data and
of course treating excel as a thesis as
an operating system as a core piece of
of the way that that we interact at
least for for the time being and for the
short and perhaps long-term future
within teams but at the end this
question of planning and what does it
take to do planning and where the
different bottlenecks and perhaps it is
not just the the the ability to ask the
smart questions which i think is part of
the underlying assumption here is that
the we we do have the ability as humans
not to ask the right questions but we do
have a challenge in understanding
where's the data how do we consolidate
it and how do we use it
so that we can leverage excel and and
the current capabilities to answer those
questions and it sounds like you found a
really really cool
piece here in this puzzle of how to
leverage interesting technology to make
this consolidation and to make a
positive impact and so it sounds
fantastic and i really want to thank you
for coming here and for sharing with me
in these 20 short minutes it was a very
enjoyable thank you thank you very much
i enjoyed myself
thank you bye
[Music]